well one thing we do know ahead of Mike
Pence's speech is that the slogan for
today is making America first again a
sign of the populist right-wing message
at this convention which of course has
many foreign visitors amongst those here
are Nigel Farage the leader of the UK
Independence Party and joining me now
hair builders of the Dutch Freedom Party
welcome do you describe yourself as the
next next dutch prime minister what why
are you here well I'm invited by friends
friendly politician from Tennessee that
I know for a very long time
and of course it's the heart of the
American democracy we know since
yesterday who the candidate will be of
one of the two parties in the United
States and to be here is very I'm very
honored to be here and to Ferguson I
mean that nationalist message making
America great again America first that
accords with your view for your country
well you know not only my view I think
that what you see happening today in the
United States is quite similar what you
see all over Europe we see that a
growing amount of people feel
misrepresented feel even abandoned by
their political leaders the political
leader day they see problems every day
when it comes to losing their jobs or
terrorism or immigration or Islamization
or crime even often on a daily basis and
and they see that the current leaders
are not addressing it are still being
very politically correct and now we have
a leader I hope it will be the next
president of the United States
that's as well and I'm not being
politically correct I'm going to address
all those issues and the normal people
what the Americans call the blue-collar
people are very enthusiastic about that
then you see in Europe with my party and
other countries the rise of similar
parties as well you would agree with
what Donald Trump now calls his
suggestion of banning all Muslims coming
into the United States why not and I
think and I have to agree with that kind
of policy I believe that not all Muslims
are bad people but I believe that the
Islam them is something that and goes
not together with liberty and with
freedom and we have where this open-door
policy of the last decades in all of
Europe we have without having any
demands of
Malaysian of an integration because of
this political correctness of the
millions of people who came to our
society and I always tell my American
friends if you let its Lomb being seated
on your soil don't be surprised that you
are half as to Sharia law I mean they're
more the billion Muslims in the world
keep them out of North America or in the
Western Europe but I think we have to
once again not because all those people
are bad people it would be ridiculous to
suggest that all Muslims are terrorists
but almost all terrorists are Muslims
today you cannot close your eyes for
that so indeed I would if I would become
the prime minister of the Netherlands
next year after I would win the
elections close the Dutch borders for
immigrants from Islamic countries
immediately you only be able to develop
course if you followed Britain out of
the European Union exactly I mean in
order we transferred our sovereign
rights not only when it comes to our
monetary policy or our budgetary policy
but also our immigration policy and we
transfer that to Brussels so we have to
regain our you'll hold a referendum we
would hold a referendum in the
Netherlands for what we call an exit the
Dutch leaving in order to be able and to
toughen up our immigration policies it
cannot be done and it will not be done
by Brussels and the European Union you
have to become a sovereign nation again
in order to do that if what about most
people already in Holland let me know
you have a history of colonialism like
we do which includes people of that
religious faith what do you do about
that
listen if people are and in the
Netherlands already and if they abide by
our laws and our Constitution they are
not only free to stay but equal as
anybody know Gotham is a threat
nonetheless
no not the people I regret or I see the
Islamic ideology as a threat I see it
more as a totalitarian ideology than a
religion so if the people abide by our
laws they are welcome to stay but if
they as they often unfortunately do if
they start acting according to Sharia
law and commit crimes and they have a
double nationality I believe we should
strip them of the dutch nationality and
sound unpacking it's the only way dutch
people commit crimes as well well they
have only one nationality that will be
very hard to do most of the people from
Islamic countries in Holland
for instance the Moroccans one of the
biggest community half-double
nationality and I'm sure that there is
so much support that if you abide by our
laws you are welcome to stay we will
close the door for new immigrants from
Islamic countries if you are here you
abide by laws you're welcome but if you
commit a crime if you start acting like
Sharia law then there is no room for you
and a free society we have to defend our
freedom and the liberty and the safety
of a child you know feel that you and
perhaps Donald Trump are exploiting fear
and encouraging division in all
societies
no we are not exploiting fear you know
we are defending the freedom of our
people and all those political correct
politician that in the last decades with
the open border policy let everybody
come like I said without even the demand
of assimilation and a society in Holland
today to give you one example 73% of all
Muslims in Holland believe that Dutch
Muslims who go to fight in Syria are to
be considered heroes we cannot afford
that people have not been integrated or
assimilated so I say the good people of
course can stay but let's stop the
Islamization of our free societies in
order to stay free and liberal societies
what are you making the people here who
were describing you as a Donald Trump
look-alike well maybe it's because of my
hair I don't know and that's and now
well and I'm not a Donald Trump I'm just
hit Willis I mean you've been in
politics a long time he's a freshman
he's an outsider he's an outsider and
he's and I think very popular for that
reason as well I had a burger here at a
hamburger shop I will not mention the
name and I asked the lady who was giving
me the Big Mac I told her are you going
to vote and she said I think she was 25
years old she said for the first time I
registered to vote because I want to
vote for mr. Trump and without them I
probably would not have voted but
certainly not for the Republican Party
and I believe that if you manage to get
people in the political process to vote
you are doing a very good thing indeed
panelist thank you very much indeed